[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about whatever you want to
say
the guys want to talk about crypto
anthony wants to talk about porn
i never took you as the porno type you
put them on blast like that
why are you singling them out i'm
malfunctioning there's two topics that i
love about anal sex with dudes uh i love
porn
talk about [ __ ] orgies you're a porno
type of guy
so crypto yes yeah so like what crypto
have you guys been in lately
well my friend i'm not gonna tell you
because you won't tell me about your
porn adventure
like crypto porn oh give me that bitcoin
non-fungible tokens and non-fuckable
tokens
you gotta [ __ ] for something for some i
think their support starts buying porn
started buying
um it's gonna be an nfl though i have
teased bro athletes are doing it already
so i bet you this gumshot scene nft
you own the original yeah so how is your
crypto world going
into stuff you guys talk about though
steve's gonna be a millionaire that's
all we know
no no no we're all gonna make it dude
we're all gonna make it but the point
point being there's a lot of
sick [ __ ] going on right now and
especially in the d5 space
check out the d5 space um but bitcoin
itself
is really the one to focus what does
define me decentralized finance right so
you can
you can call that what's that is it all
of crypto that or something
i mean in a way sure you could argue
that but this is about replacing a lot
of the
banking institutions and like what their
use cases are
with crypto instead and it's all
decentralized so is bitcoin not part of
the d5 space
no it well bitcoin itself is not a defy
token in any way it's it's a transfer of
value and it's
a storage of value but you could do d5
things with yeah
especially with wrapped bitcoin or wbtc
yeah which is bitcoin on the ethereum
network
they basically tether it one-to-one with
bitcoin price-wise
and so you can actually move bitcoin
quicker via ethereum
um it's way faster it's almost like
instant yeah whenever i
swap my ethereum or like send any
ethereum coins
it's like i get it like in less than a
minute and ethereum's looking quick
about the scale layer two
really soon and bitcoin's like it takes
an hour exactly sometimes like three
hours and you're scared
shitless because you're like is my [ __ ]
just [ __ ] floating in the [ __ ]
ether
where the [ __ ] is my bitcoin because
it's not here or here i sent it from
here to here and it's like
because it's good as gold right it's
it's a really
good who's snorting not me
it was steve while he was talking about
i guess i did it no it's good as gold
right but not money
bitcoins really horrible as money
because we expect money to act quickly
if i
exchange goods for you to give me
bitcoin
yeah you expect that to be instant right
yeah bitcoin's tradable is money
but yeah if you want to move gold how
hard is that pretty hard it's difficult
heavy but as money as money there's
definitely other options including like
on the ethereum platform
when did you first start hearing about
crypto and when did you first start
investing and
what made you go i believe this one i
think it was like late 2017
wow yeah um and it was my buddy who
who's in the tech game he just got you
could have been a millionaire and you
missed out
yes over you'll never be able to make up
for it yeah that's probably
that's probably how i feel right now
that's how people are all the time you
know it's fine
that's what they said when bitcoin hit
30 000. they're like oh it's over
and it hit fifty thousand that's what
they said when i hit 20 000 yeah that's
why i'm here for the next run when it
hits a hundred thousand bro
some well this one it'll hit a hundred
thousand this summer watch
but i want to keep buying more of them
this is so important right
i remember when bitcoin hit 20 000 again
after that was the peak from
2018 right i know people who literally
sold the bitcoin they bought it 20 000
at 20
000 to break even and now here we are
and it's at 57 058 000. oh is it because
they bought it at 20 000 in 2017
when it boomed and then they saw that
long
uh bear and then they're like two years
and they're like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
to break even it went down to three
grand and then
and then people are going instead
instead instead yeah just don't [ __ ] up
like that
like if you're investing in something
invest in it
why do you think that happened so like
i'm like the opposite of that i know so
i don't
intimately so i it's
i'm trying to wrap around my mind of
people who believe
this and then they act that way because
i'm the opposite of that
so i don't naturally think that way so
i'm trying to figure out
why would people do that if you're
already gonna so to me it's like
investing or anything
it involves risk right and then you have
to be responsible for the risk
that you sign up for it's emotional
right so like
everything's emotions right the stock
market's emotions like
that's why they have like literally an
emotions index
baked into all that stuff what what does
that mean they
they pay attention to how people are
feeling about the market okay so what
so my question is what goes through
someone's mind when they invest
don't they commit to the possibility
that they might lose this money you
wronged me investment i'm mad at you now
i just want to get my money back and go
home that's literally the
mindset it's emotional then why invest
well a lot of people gambling especially
especially when things get like really
really hype
like right now a lot of people are
trying to make quick money they don't
actually think about the long-term
concepts of investment they don't even
think about like the tax repercussions
and stuff like that or like the
you know what i mean like they don't
think about diversifying their portfolio
they don't think about like actually
getting knowledge about the space or
having some sort of philosophical
foundation for why they're doing
something because you need to have a
belief factor
as well versus just like i hope to get
quick bucks you know you know i hope to
make money off this you
you got to believe in it because if it
does start to get bearish or things
start to go down
there still needs to be this intrinsic
like i still believe in this company
i still believe in this you know uh like
with crypto
and the the decentralized you know
finance there was there was this whole i
think we did like a jk news episode
a couple years ago talking about like
centralized banking systems and stuff
like that too right
people being controls people being the
shadows few people like having the
the power to like kind of exactly to to
control
so much because they control the money
um conspiracies where you have to follow
the money yeah
they don't even know this [ __ ] but
they're throwing money at it and then
getting sour when they lose it
yeah so once they lose it they're just
like oh no it's not gonna come back i
just lost let me cut my losses versus
having a belief in what they even
invested in the beginning so that
they're short-sighted
exactly and then they [ __ ] up and then
they start sending me articles about
hey did you see that this article says
bitcoin's a scam and i'm like oh my god
you're
you're basically just monkeys in a
barreling trying to get me to sell
because
you're sad that you missed out and it's
it's a blog get some guy that just
writes a
bitcoin dude i've seen a quora post from
a [ __ ] phd who's like
here's why bitcoins fool's gold and i'm
like dude you
just have your head up your own [ __ ]
ass so when people
are like trying to counter you with
different articles and stuff right
like i do that because i want to hear
your perspective yeah
to gauge if i'm thinking right
yeah they're doing it in a way to
confirm that they
are right they are right
it's reddit butt coin so people care
more about being right than making money
look is that what it is dude reddit but
coin is dedicated to this
it's basically like reddit butt coin
it's called butt coin it's basically
like um
ha ha we were right about bitcoin every
time that bitcoin dips they're like haha
we were right about bitcoin ooh they're
just sour there's people
but but they're like peter schiff they
all get he was the gold guy yeah that
guy gets wrecked every time bitcoin goes
up because people spam his twitter like
hey [ __ ] you petership i'm
i'm gonna be richer than you soon and
this cat is basically like
buy gold that's where he's at
damn yeah i mean gold did go up who's
the gold always goes up but gold just
went down actually
who's the guy that always yells at peter
schiff the bitcoin guy the guy with the
glasses which one
there's a bunch huh no he's the guy he's
i've been seeing him on my instagram
and it's like on my explore page and
he's just always yelling at peter schiff
he was one ripping up ten dollars in his
face damn
did you guys see that guy i'm surprised
i don't know yeah i was i was gonna be
like i mean
as soon as i mentioned him i thought you
glasses he has glasses
bitcoin or ethereum what's his thing oh
i think i don't know if it's bitcoin or
ethereum but he's a he's a crypto
currency a bitcoin max but
and if you understand how like money
works right you can't go wrong
with telling people to buy metal like
silver and gold
because the way that the money supply
works is just printed
so like sure it deflates so then when
you buy
metal you're keeping it in your car it
always goes higher no but like that's
what you do
is you're like physically keeping this
no no when you buy you might be
investing into it
yeah you can there's different ways to
get it like you can get gold bricks but
you can also like
buy into a fawn that has metal or
whatever but
the idea is people don't understand how
inflation works right like so a cup of
coffee used to be like 25 cent or
whatever it'll never be that cheap ever
again
you can't go to a diner and get a
[ __ ] coffee for 25 cents unless it's
1950's day right because every year we
lose
um like three percent to to to inflation
right and then the
the the thing is so now that with the
stimulus checks and everything
we dumped so much [ __ ] money we just
devalued the [ __ ] out of our dollar but
cash is king bro
it's oh don't worry yeah so like the b
is cash if you have 10 000
on you right now 20 years from now
that'll probably be like eight
who knows right or left today's video is
brought to you
by upstart and you know
i had a lot of credit card debt after
graduating
university as most people do you know
and it was a tough time for me because i
had
about forty thousand dollars in debt and
i wish i had this exact
thing because you know what happens with
credit cards is we have this thing
called
apr an apr interest it's the same thing
but to you know use their money to
borrow the credit card's
money right you could pay for things or
whatever they're like i'll let you
borrow it
but i'm gonna put a percentage on for
holding on to my money
and so even though i'm paying back the
minimum
what ended up happening is like i'm
owing more and more money and i'm like
how am i gonna get out of this debt
because like i'm not making enough to
ever pay this off
so i was lucky enough at the time to
find
a situation where i was able to get
another credit card and get this
you know lower rate and then i got to
put it all in there
but here's the thing if i had upstart i
would totally do that
because swift just swapping from like
credit card to credit card
is insane it's risky it's dangerous it's
just
you know you might not be approved for
that much there's like a whole lot of
headache behind it but if i had this
opportunity in college i would 100
do this because they don't go based off
of your credit score they don't go based
off of like anything but
your income they go based off of your
income
your job things like education education
and it's more of a fair way in my
opinion of how they evaluate
like if you could pay back or not and
what's dope is if you get up you get
approved the same day
and then the money comes the next
business day so if you're in a shitty
situation
and you do try to do the whole credit
card thing you got to wait until they
mail you one
that's exactly what happened and then so
during that whole time you could be
still compounding interest that you owe
people with this one the money comes
super fast so find out how upstart can
help lower your monthly payment go to
upstart.com
off the record upstart.com off the
record and make sure
you use our url because
i want them to know that we sent you yep
and loan amounts
will be based off of your credit income
and other things that are in your loan
application
go to upstart.com off the record is that
what happened to
because i don't i don't know history but
i do know that in mexico
they used to have a different kind of
like bills like different
vessels and i had a whole bunch of old
bills that i don't like it would say
like 10 000
pesos or something and it was worth very
little that'll usually be based off of
inflation yeah but then yeah like what
happened there where they ended up
changing their
entire career they might have moved
their decimal or like
all that cash just was like devalued
like crazy that's like the zimbabwe
dollars right
yeah yeah that means that they printed
too much so is that what's gonna happen
to the dollar
that's already happened that's happening
now so this is why
everyone's buying real estate and it's
called hedging right so like
like moving your money into different
things that's gonna hold value
so like if you buy a house right now the
price of the house and all this stuff
might go up because the dollar
is getting weaker so you're moving your
money into something
that is kind of protecting the value of
what you own
so if you have cash you know you're kind
of out of luck
like people who save money are
losing money by saving it yeah if you if
you have like a hundred thousand fifty
thousand into like a savings account in
a bank right now by the end of the month
uh you're you're losing money for sure
but they think
they i i was sent the boys
um this ad recently remember that it was
like citibank or somebody and they're
like
like we have hyper um hyper savings
uh it's like 0.5 apr it's point it's not
even one percent
half a percent it's a half a percent apr
and they're bragging about it and they
they literally hate you like hyper
interest if you know
what the banks think they literally
think that you're a piece of [ __ ]
and that you because they all collude
together and they all get to collect
interest off of your money that they use
to make more money but they don't pay
you for it which is what banking was
supposed to be about
uh they think that you're so stupid that
you look at 0.5
apr with your coffee mug in the morning
or you're ready i'm investing baby
what a deal it doesn't even beat
inflation so technically
if your money doesn't bring you back
more than three percent
you're losing money so if the savings
account or whatever
we're gonna give you back point five
percent
the fed is a cartel it's they're they're
lose and they collude with the banks
and then they basically are going like
hey here's your 0.5 percent while we
devalue your currency
like joe's saying three percent so guess
what 2.5
haven't like like you lost 2.5 then
so the goal is like okay you make money
in your job or as your business or
whatever right
and then you want to save that money and
then if you want to save it you want it
to
last throughout your lifetime because
you don't want to be like so like let's
say our grandparents generation
or before them during the great
depression everyone was like safe safe
safe right
because things weren't in uh fleeting at
the rate as they are now
so but it still is like you could buy a
car back then for like what eight
thousand bucks ten thousand dollars or
whatever
so imagine if you worked hella hard back
then and you saved up ten thousand
dollars because back then ten thousand
dollars was like
maybe sixty thousand now and you left it
in your account
till now you can't buy the same [ __ ]
with ten thousand dollars
that's the whole point not to dunk too
hard on this entire topic but if you
took
me and joe's money masters course even
as a joke
that's true last year we had some pretty
dope crypto tips in there but people
made money
people made tons of money so you know
yeah what were some of the tips what's
like uh
were you talking about bitcoin ethereum
all the stuff that was in like bargain
prices literally the bottom of the
market yeah last year
if you bought it at that time dude
people who's even just put in 100 bucks
have been killing it i told you we
should have signed up
for the money master scores money
masters it's funny because everyone's
[ __ ] all over it and they're like how
dare you guys all this [ __ ] but like bro
people got mad at you for that well
yeah about everything dude people always
get mad when you're trying to sell stuff
anybody who took that course and just
did a couple of those moves
is [ __ ] drop kick in the end we
didn't even tell people
anything that was like out of this world
nope it's like think about it right you
guys saw
right now the proof of ethereum and
bitcoin
2019 2020
everyone was still saying that it's over
crypto's over
you're not going to make any more
right where are they now all those
[ __ ] i bet you they forgot
i bet you they even forgot that they
said those things
yep they don't own it they certainly
they certainly don't apologize and they
certainly don't own it that's for sure
definitely bitcoin's at
57 800 something 57 right oh [ __ ]
it's just going on wait was it 2019 when
we did that no 2020. we did it during 20
during the
during the 14th the bottom in the middle
of the coin was in april three grand
that's so crazy last year yeah at 2020.
yeah
and we told people dude just [ __ ]
blow up
buy bitcoin buy ethereum yeah my
friend's girlfriend bought some
some good alt tips yeah and then some of
our students messaged us back and we're
like yo thanks man i paid off my school
loans and all that stuff
and we didn't say anything that was
like anything that that's super special
no we didn't even tell them to buy it we
just said
like look into this [ __ ] start start
checking this [ __ ] out diversify
in your thoughts like and not just like
in your portfolio
but right so diversify thoughts well
so like if i'm the type of person so if
i'm the type of person right who's like
oh bitcoin's a scam
crypto's a scam i was told it's a scam
my dad really thinks so so i'm not gonna
research scams why would i do that to
waste the time right you're not
diversifying your thoughts like critical
thinking about
this you're a person on quora i saw this
post somebody
linked it on one of the crypto reddits
but it's basically like do people who
are invested in cryptocurrencies realize
that it's a scam
and that's such a highfalutin thing like
to look down an entire industry it's
worth
100 1.7 trillion dollars right now
and go it's all a scam yeah like it's if
it's such a scam why don't
you buy like one point something billion
into it why are all these companies
buying in why you're dumping in
trillions of dollars why is the nasdaq
about to um
they're about to have a list of
companies that have bought into bitcoin
and ethereum why why i think that
anyone who just writes things off
simply simplistic like reasoning to do
it like
like for example right i mean like this
is the core of how racism or things like
stereotypes
are formed in a human's mind like
they're so simplistic
that they go they write off a whole
entire group and then they say oh it's
because of this reason don't you know
they're already like that oh yeah
they're all this way
right and then so if you have and hold
this type of mentality and it's not for
comedy because it's fun to play with
tropes
but if you're really thinking this way
you're never going to be successful at
anything
in my opinion it's because you write it
off and you don't do the due diligence
to investigate
well even if it is a scam like look into
it
why is it yeah you know and then usually
people can't answer
and or they're just regurgitating
whatever [ __ ] like bullet points
cmbc or
whatever they said something to flood it
by the way so that they can drive the
price of bitcoin down so they can all
buy bitcoin for cheaper
rates out of all the bitcoin like uh i
guess
excuses that people say why not to buy
bitcoin i just don't understand it
what's yeah what's the most frustrating
one
i just don't understand it so i can't
buy it because i don't understand if i
don't understand how blockchain works i
can't buy it
literally you don't even need to use
blockchain to buy it
but it's fine well here's another are
you squaring i like square cash
cash app real estate is great and
i'm making on passive income what i
probably had to pump half a million
dollars or more
into to get the same amount of passive
income no actually i probably have to
pump in a million dollars
to pum to get this kind of passive
income and i'm doing that on a quarter
of the price
so it just sucks that
right now we're sitting on a gold mine
and you can argue that it's short-term
not long-term and it's volatile and it's
fine
agreed it's all about timing i think
that's what it is right like
during the dot-com boom of you know the
80s or 90s 90s
when when this happened a lot of people
got
[ __ ] extremely rich a lot of people
failed too
but it's all about timing and moving it
at the right so
it's like success is relative to people
who can time it right
well it's a cycle though it's all cycle
but but this but the idea that this is
all
just a big [ __ ] scam and then it's
it's just a ponzi and every time there's
new people buying the ponzi and selling
on top of the other people's heads
you're not actually looking into the
ecosystem what these companies are doing
what these projects are about like the
fact that people can buy and sell
and lend and become a bank right now and
lend their crypto or borrow their crypto
against somebody else's crypto right now
you can do all this [ __ ] without
anybody's permission
it's literally a threat to the
institutions of the world a threat to
the fed a threat to the war economy that
we have that literally drives
everything which is a scam correct
that's the real scam
so is fiat currency it's a real [ __ ]
scam actually and if you look into it
your mind is not backed by anything yeah
but people when they see
established things that becomes the
baseline
of what is true to them so if they were
born into this world and the banking
system already existed
that becomes the institution of
credibility right
so like you just gotta get into the
psychology of like
the way people think and like they're
like oh this is the truth so i'm going
based off of
first and foremost fiat which is like
you know the money that we use this is
what i'm used to this is my
you know and then so i think
understanding new ideas
or success or like making money also
comes from
being able to go a little bit outside of
that
and then finding opportunity because at
the end of the day i think what people
are looking for
is a for sure bet without any risk
because it's scary
and then this whole time i'm trying to
think about the psychology behind people
who invest and then they get angry that
they lose money
because everything there's winners and
losers most of those people though
remember like most of those people who
don't even understand though or jump in
they're jumping even to speak about it
right now is because it's on a hype
train right now right like people
weren't talking about it like this
uh a year ago or the people who were
talking about before
yeah the people who are talking about it
though are the people who maybe are
understanding it or really paying
attention or at the same time are
winning from it right
but when suddenly it becomes like mass
popular culture it's like every article
right like a bunch of like
different hedge funds are jumping in a
bunch of different corporations are
jumping in
now when everybody starts to talk about
it that's when it in
in and of itself like inflates to a
point where there's probably going to be
a correction right ultimately
there's gonna be always corrections so
that being said because it's hype people
start jumping in which means that once
the correction hits of course
a lot of people are going to lose money
now and then they're going to preach all
their friends and families like no i
lost money on it so
you only lose money there's winners and
losers in the marketplace which is a
great thing right because because this
is like the 21st century
gold rush and if i'm if i'm a gold miner
i don't actually want to tell everybody
to go mine for gold
i'll tell my close friends and family
and then i'll be like don't tell anybody
else
but that's as a gold mine right so see
i'm ideologically driven
into this to push the the currency
exactly
i hate the petro dollar i hate the way
that basically everything in our world
is run by cartels and by the fed
and i believe in this as a way as an
actual
um hedge against our system which is i
just want a lot of money so i could eat
steaks every day yeah
you